the jurgen experience so there's
there's pros and cons there but my point
was that
there is something to the ego in that
regard where
i think you almost have to have it to be
michael jordan right for instance
who had a tremendous ego huge yeah but
also
one of the greatest if not the greatest
basketball player of all
time but obsessed do you ever see the
video
jamie actually played it for me once
there was a video where this uh
guy was talking [ __ ] about michael
jordan after he retired
and so michael jordan came back and
played him one-on-one and just
watched him scorched him well he's
talking [ __ ] the whole time who was that
jamie
did you blame me that no it's happened
multiple times though i mean in a
documentary they go over
five or six different situations where
he's going back over someone that slided
him in this in the tiniest way
and just wrecked havoc on 40 points on
them
yeah called them like you would act like
they don't exist all sorts of funny
stuff
yeah he was his ego was substantial
and is i'm sure but also the results are
substantial
right and that's the and so the question
i wonder and this is really a question
because i don't get to study
high performance athletes with
narcissism work you don't get to do it i
mean you can
imagine that you get data from
presidents and stuff that you can get
from historians but
you just don't really have the data and
i wonder it you know like obviously from
muhammad ali and stuff and that sort of
braggadocio before fights
that if in those combat sports ego is
super important to develop
i mean theoretically it makes sense you
know one-on-one competition
it's not about a team it's you just have
to win
up to a point i would say well what i
was saying before is that
the people that get destroyed who have
these enormous egos
when they get exposed it takes
incredible character to build yourself
back
up and some never do some get
psychologically defeated and they're
never the same again
because the the pain of loss and the
pain of being exposed
as being inferior to your opponent is
just too much but i wonder
like that is that such a rare example
of when it would be beneficial to be
narcissistic or beneficial to have an
ego
tremendously i mean it's but you know if
you look across the literature the place
it seems to work is individual
competitiveness
because if you're in a team so imagine
you know you see this in teams all the
time so the old story is the quarterback
gets
goes in front of the cameras and goes
yeah i want it for the team and the next
time the front line just lets the
defense through and the quarterback's
dead
so he goes next time he wins he goes
yeah i just want to thank my team and
god
and then the team supports him because
in a team sport you can't be really
successful without a team maybe
maybe basketball a little bit but like
football and stuff
so it keeps that ego in check but with
boxing or fight it's just you
it is but it also is a team as well
because you need a coach
you need someone to train you correctly
and in tyson's case
when his coach died when customato died
and then
he his relationship with his coaches
afterwards deteriorated to the point
where he really was just having like
bucket carriers
in in the ring yeah he his career faded
so you need a back office kind of you
need someone you respect too
you need someone who's like hey man you
keep dropping your [ __ ] left hand
stop doing that
you're like okay okay okay thank you
like you need someone who sees your
failures and your mistakes and and
checks you on them and you need to
respect that person so does michael
jordan have that person who
i think michael jordan was so hard on
himself
and so like so obsessed with winning
i mean i think this is why i wanted to
bring him up because i think there's
psychological
issues that these extreme winners have
that you don't get to where they are
without them
it's like the where the illness becomes
beneficial
right if you're not sadistic you don't
make a good serial killer
right or a good internet troll yeah
but if you're not if you're not
narcissistic or ego you're an egomaniac
i wonder
if you ever become a guy like michael
jordan who's just
so dominant well he's an example
of somebody who's very egotistical i
mean that's the i don't know him i don't
but that's the what people say
he's very competitive you know and it's
obviously work form
um and you see it with all so the other
option might be that
well if you're kind of a dick and you're
really really good people will let you
get away with it
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love